Venezuela es un país del que se habla hasta
la saciedad en todos los medios de fuera pero
muy poquito en los de dentro.
Por ejemplo, los que veáis este vídeo desde España, ya sabéis que la crisis política
y el colapso económico de Venezuela está
en la boca de todos los políticos de Madrid.
- "Yo no estoy de acuerdo con muchas cosas que hace el gobierno de Venezuela"
- "La situación de extrema gravedad en Venzuela".
- "Para Venezuela"
- "Empieza por v..."
Sin embargo, si entráis en la web de una
de las televisiones públicas Venezolanas,
como puede ser TELESUR, encontraréis noticias
de todos los países del mundo menos de Venezuela.
Para que os hagáis una idea, mientras preparaba
este vídeo, eché un vistazo a la portada
de este medio.
De 29 noticias que tenían destacadas, sólo
5 se referían a su propio país.
En este momento ya no hay nadie que ponga
en duda que Venezuela pasa por una crisis
humanitaria.
Según un estudio realizado por tres universidades
del país, el venezolano medio ha perdido
entre 9 y 10 kilos de peso en los últimos
dos años debido la escasez de comida.
Lo que no está tan claro es la responsabilidad
de su gobierno.
¿Cómo está respondiendo Nicolás Maduro
a esta situación?
Para muchos políticos y analistas, Venezuela
es ya, oficialmente, una dictadura.
Cosas como intentar disolver el parlamento
o encarcelar a los políticos de la oposición
o intentar disolver el Parlamento
han desencadenado reacciones diplomáticas al más alto nivel.
-"El retiro del embajador de Perú en Venezuela fue respaldado por el Parlamento".
Sin embargo, no sobran quienes mantienen que
Venezuela sigue siendo un país completamente
democrático.
Incluso que Nicolás Maduro se está defendiendo
de un intento de golpe de estado
Y la pregunta es ¿Quién de los dos tiene razón?
¿Podemos decir que Venezuela es una dictadura  o es una exageración?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta.
Pero antes, vamos a ver la historia que cuenta
el propio gobierno de Nicolás Maduro.
Según Nicolás Maduro, la crisis venezolana se resume
en una conspiración de Estados Unidos y sus
aliados por acabar con la revolución bolivariana.
- "La élite imperialista que desprecia a nuestros pueblos.
Qué tiene como objetivo la destrucción de la independencia, de la democracia y de la vida en paz
de nuestra patria. Ellos han decidido activar planes para desestabilizar a la sociedad venezolana".
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando… ¡Pero vamos
a asumir que esta teoría tiene sentido!
En este caso la “burguesía internacional”
no sólo quería colapsar la economía de
Venezuela sino también derrocar al gobierno.
Y eso explica el miedo de Nicolás Maduro
a que le den un golpe de estado.
¡Pero esperad un momento!
Porque antes de continuar, deberíamos definir…
¿Qué es un golpe de estado?
Un golpe de estado se define como la toma
de poder repentina y violenta mediante un
grupo de poder, normalmente, el ejército
¿Y cuál es el problema aquí?
¡Pues que el ejército de Venezuela es completamente
afín a Nicolás Maduro!
Incluso el propio Hugo Chávez había estado
en las Fuerzas Armadas.
Es más, a diferencia de otros países como
España, donde la ley prohíbe que los militares
se metan en política, en Venezuela hay varios
ministros que vienen de las Fuerzas Armadas.
Aquí tenemos a la Almirante Melendez Rivas,
ministra de Presidencia, o al General Marco
Torres, ministro de Alimentación… en total,
un tercio de los ministros venezolanos son
militares.
Dicho esto ¿Quién podría entonces dar ese
supuesto golpe de estado al gobierno de
Nicolas Maduro?
Pues efectivamente, los partidos políticos
de la oposición ¿El problema?
Que ninguno de ellos tiene relación con el
ejército.
Es decir, que tanto Enrique Capriles, como
Leopoldo López, como todos los demás líderes
opositores son políticos de carrera o empresarios
y no tienen ningún relación
ni con las fuerzas armadas ni con ningún grupo paramilitar que los apoye.
Pese a todo esto, el Gobierno insiste en que
estos políticos de oposición son los que
están detrás de la violencia callejera.
Como os podéis imaginar, en un país donde
la gente llega a pagar el sueldo de un día
entero sólo para comprar un kilo de cebollas,
es completamente normal que haya protestas
en la calle ¿No os parece?
Sumadle a eso el hecho de que Caracas es la
ciudad más violenta de todo Latinoamérica
y entenderéis por qué muchas de estas manifestaciones
terminan así.
Sin embargo, para el Gobierno de Venezuela,
los enfrentamientos entre policía y manifestantes
son el producto de la propaganda opositora.
En septiembre de 2015, 3 meses antes de las
elecciones legislativas, la policía venezolana
arrestaba a Leopoldo López, que era el líder
de uno de los partidos adversarios de Maduro.
La acusación aseguraba que este hombre estaba
incitando a la violencia con declaraciones
como esta.
“¿No tienes las agallas para meterme preso?
¿O esperas órdenes de la Habana?
Te lo digo: la verdad está de nuestro lado”.
Pero el auténtico punto de inflexión vino
más tarde, concretamente en diciembre de 2015.
En esos días, Venezuela celebró elecciones
parlamentarias.
Los distintos partidos de la oposición, aglutinados
en lo que llaman la MESA DE UNIDAD DEMOCRÁTICA
o, como se la conoce habitualmente, la MUD,
consiguieron ganar a la formación de Maduro
por más de 2 millones de votos.
En un principio, la reacción del mandatario
venezolano fue la que cabría esperar en cualquier
país democrático.
- "A reconocer estos resultados adversos, a aceptarlos".
¿Pero qué es lo primero que hace esta asamblea
nacional con mayoría antiMaduro?
Pues intentan convocar una moción de censura
contra el presidente para organizar elecciones
presidenciales anticipadas.
Y aquí es cuando, de repente, Nicolás Maduro
y su camarilla cambian radicalmente de opinión.
-"Cuando digo ha triunfado la guerra económica es porque el terror que le metieron
a la vida económica de nuestro pueblo, inhibió a un porcentaje importante y viró las corrientes".
Durante estos últimos dos años, las relaciones entre Maduro y la Asamblea Nacional han sido muy tensas.
E incluso, el gobierno de Venezuela ha tratado de disolver la Asamblea Nacional.
Según el Gobierno, algunos de esos diputados
habían sido elegidos de forma fraudulenta.
Pero ni siquiera el tribunal superior de justicia
aceptó esa versión.
Y por eso, el 1 de mayo de 2017, Maduro ha
tomado el punto de no retorno.
- "Yo convoco el poder constituyente originario para lograr la paz que necesita la republica,
para derrocar el golpe fascista y para que sea el pueblo con su soberanía quien imponga la paz".
En otras palabras, Maduro quiere constituir
un nuevo parlamento que se encargaría de
redactar una nueva constitución.
Este nuevo texto le daría poderes plenos
al presidente y podría ser el paso definitivo
a una dictadura.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Va a convocar elecciones?
En teoría sí.
Pero lo cierto es que, desde 2015 hay decenas
de opositores políticos en las cárceles
Según el gobierno todos ellos son unos golpistas, así que ya me contareis
cómo pueden ser unas elecciones democráticas donde no hay partidos de oposición.
Pero y ¿Qué pasa con los medios de comunicación?
Los defensores del Nicolás Maduro aseguran
que Venezuela tiene libertad de expresión
como cualquier otro país pero… ¿Es eso
verdad?
Según la Constitución venezolana, la libertad
de expresión es un derecho fundamental.
Y es cierto que existen varios periódicos
que no apoyan al gobierno ¿Pero sabéis cual
es su problema?
¡Que no tienen papel para imprimirlos!
Tal cual.
En Venezuela, la importación y venta de papel
es un monopolio regulado por el Estado.
Y por eso, periódicos antichavistas o antimaduro
como puedan ser EL NACIONAL han tenido que reducir
su tirada y hasta su tamaño.
Otros diarios han pasado a ser semanales porque
no podían imprimirse.
¡Y os preguntaréis!
¿Qué pasa con Internet?
Lo cierto es que en este ámbito, el Gobierno
de Maduro también tiene poder absoluto para
bloquear cualquier página web por absurda
que parezca ¿Habéis oído hablar de BIT.LY?
Se trata de una web donde pones un enlace
y te lo hacen más corto para que puedas emplearlo
en Twitter.
Pues atentos:
“Los links acortados de BIT.LY están prohibidos
en Venezuela”
Como os podréis imaginar, si Bit.ly está
prohibido, también lo están otras páginas
mucho más peligrosas para el Gobierno como
la CNN, DólarToday o InfoBAE.
Todas estas webs son inaccesibles desde Venezuela
a no ser que utilices una conexión PROXI.
Y, por supuesto, a todo esto hay que sumarle
las detenciones a los más de 40 periodistas
amenazados por grupos cercanos al gobierno,
o incluso peor.
“Al menos seis tuiteros se encuentran detenidos
en Venezuela por opinar”
Habéis oído bien: detenidos, no juzgados.
Gente que está en la cárcel.
Pero sin duda alguna, el medio más castigado
por el Gobierno de Venezuela es la TELEVISIÓN.
Durante décadas, Caracas fue algo así como
el Hollywood de las telenovelas latinoamericanas.
Eso que en España conocemos como los “culebrones”
y que ven nuestras abuelas después de comer.
Pues bien, casi todas estas series se producían
en Venezuela.
Y eso significa que este país siempre ha
tenido muchísimas cadenas de televisión
privadas.
Y, lógicamente, muchas de ellas tienen una
línea editorial contraria a los intereses
de Nicolás Maduro.
Otra vez más, la constitución de Venezuela
reconoce la libertad de expresión de estas
televisiones.
Pero, por otro lado, hay una ley que las obliga
a emitir los discursos del presidente ¡Y
no creáis que hablamos de un programa al
año!
Maduro sale por la tele varias veces por semana.
Y todas las emisoras de televisión, tanto
públicas como privadas, tienen que interrumpir
su programación para ofrecer el sermón del
presidente, que a veces se alarga durante
horas.
A todo esto hay que sumar operaciones tan
sospechosas como esta.
“Venden TV Venezolana GLOBOVISIÓN y anuncian
una nueva línea editorial de centro”
Antes de que Maduro fuera presidente, en la
época de Hugo Chávez, Globovisión era una
de las televisiones más críticas con el
gobierno.
Y en el año 2013, cambio de manos.
Y sus nuevos dueños tienen conexiones directas
con el chavismo.
Nada más llegar, despiden a la mitad de la
plantilla y, de repente, Globovisión se convierte
en una televisión “de centro”.
Y este sólo es un ejemplo, pero hay muchísimos más.
Dicho esto, sólo cabe hacer una pregunta
¿En qué se diferencia Nicolás Maduro de
cualquier dictador en el que podamos pensar?
¿De verdad alguien puede afirmar que Venezuela
sigue siendo una democracia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis entender por qué
Venezuela está en crisis y cuales son las
razones que han llevado a este país al colapso,
haced click en este vídeo.
¡Y por cierto!
Tenemos que daros las gracias a todos los
que estáis haciendo donaciones a nuestra
cuenta de PayPal.
Es una ayuda importantísima para poder continuar
y mejorar el trabajo que hacemos en VisualPolitik.
Así que muchas gracias porque vosotros lo
estáis haciendo posible.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!